I mean we're back on Washington journal
with Anna Nelson from American
University who served on the JFK Review
Board established by the JFK Records Act
of 1992 good morning good morning thank
you for joining us so how and why was
the review board set up what did you do
well Congress passed a statute in 1992
largely as a result of the Oliver Stone
movie people had suspected the Warren
Commission for years and years and years
of hiding something and then when the
movie came out large numbers of people
felt that their the idea of conspiracy
had been truly proven by the movie so
Congress some members of Congress
feeling that they didn't really like the
idea of having the government suspected
of being part of a conspiracy decided
that perhaps it was time to not
investigate but release the documents we
were not an investigating committee we
did not come to a decision on any way of
who killed the president it was our job
to open every record we could find so
that a large number of people can go use
those records and make up their own mind
we were chosen by the president under
the provisions of the statute and the
Congress suggested to the president that
we be professionals who reckon
represented the two historical
organizations the two major historical
organizations in the country the
American Historical Association and the
Organization of American Historians
which is just Americanists the arc of
archival organization the Society of
American archivists and then the
National Bar Association one of our
members had to be a lawyer and one of
our members was chosen by the president
who also chose a historian so there were
four historians and a lawyer now I
noticed on the cover of the report that
you all issued the statement all
government records concerning the
assassination of President John F
Kennedy
Kennedy should carry a presumption of
immediate disclosure is that a
conclusion you came to or were those
your marching orders those were our
marching orders and that was the final
statement in the in our nominating
committee we had we were we were picked
by the president but we had to be
approved by the Senate government
affairs committee and those were the
last words given to us the statute also
says that we must proceed on a
presumption of openness
none of these documents are closed
forever
the they're closed for 25 years which
means in 2017 unless the agencies come
back and protest they are open even the
ones that we decided for various reasons
should be closed for a while
largely those were imposing on privacy
rules and threatening we felt certain
release of certain names with threatened
officials and and there were some
technical operations that we had to
cover we were dealing with very
high-level records and we were dealing
with not only the Central Intelligence
Agency and that and the FBI but also the
National Security Agency which is one of
our most secretive agencies and many
other government agencies well our calls
have already started coming in we're
going to let you we brought some visual
aids to show us the daunting nature of
the task facing you but first let's take
our first call in the moderate line from
Columbia South Carolina good morning
good morning yes I'd like to know if Lee
Harvey Oswald did not kill JFK who did
well you're asking a question of who did
it and that's not what we were supposed
to do what we did do was to look into
every corner for information on Lee
Harvey Oswald and we found a lot of it
and we found a lot that had not been
released one of these documents for
example that one over there to Adair was
left was a document that we found that
was totally black and when it
was cleared for being open want to get
the other one
it just it said something we didn't know
about Lee Harvey Oswald that basically
he had tried to go to Switzerland on his
way to the Soviet Union this was the
kind of work we did we did not decide on
who killed the president this report
that you issued is this available to the
public it is not available to public in
that form because that actually is a
copy that we had printed the GPO the
government printing office is going to
complete the report that we picked a
nicer cover of reports as soon as they
can it I think it probably another week
or two they'll be available for GPO and
they can be ordered from them
unfortunately our board is now out of
business so you have to get them from
the government however I will say that
the entire report is on a couple of
websites one of them is the organization
of American historian website The
Washington Post considered putting it on
I don't know if they ever concluded to
do it and it may be on the National
Archives website at some point so we
prepared a great many CDs I guess they
are for websites and with the assumption
that people who were not close to a GPA
a government printing office store or
someone who didn't want to pay the price
would be able to read the report caller
from Gramm North Carolina on our
conservative line good morning yes good
morning I was wondering if the
Commission or the committee there has
received any photographs or any other
documentation from the American public
since the assassination to influence the
report and I was wondering if the new
technology has made any inroads in
finding out some information about the
assassination that wasn't revealed or
reported in the past thank you
actually that we did use some new
technology
we were graciously very graciously Kodak
offered without my pay to enhance the
autopsy records now those records are
still in the possession of the County
family but we felt like we were the last
opportunity to clear up some of these
issues and that perhaps ultimately in
the far distant future they would be
available they are always they always
have been available to pathologists and
other people who would petition to see
them and so we did enhance those autopsy
records to the point where they are much
clearer we also assured that the saputo
film was digitalized properly and not
just commercially and we received a
number of films and photographs one was
taken by the president's friend Dave
powers who was in a car behind the
president during the ride to Dealey
Plaza unfortunately his film ran out
before the assassination but the film is
very interesting anyway because it does
show the motorcade and it shows it's
really kind of tragic it shows a very
happy cheerful President and mrs.
Kennedy and it's a valuable film then we
also would obtain many outtakes from
news people who had published you know
the newspapers don't take every single
picture that you that the photographer
takes and many of them had saved those
outtakes and we obtained a number of
those so we have it I guess we have
enhanced greatly the visual side we made
a plea for film and photographs and we
did get some that had been put away on
our liberal I'm from Chicago Illinois
good morning good morning how are you
fine thank you my question is now that
you've done the research and opened up
these areas was what was the most
surprising thing you found and what is
the next step well I suppose the next
step is for people who are truly
interested in those people who have in
fact spent many many hours and days and
months and years of their lives
investigating the assassination to now
go to the National Archives they're
finding a door our finding age for these
documents is again on the web and I
think that's the next step the next step
has to go come from historians and
researchers in terms of what we found
that was most surprising I think the
first thing was the sheer number of
documents four million pages are now in
the archives now we did not look at all
of that we were instructed only to look
at those documents but the agencies were
covering up either in part or in whole
and so our job was to look at documents
that that looked like the black document
over here and open them up and this we
did and we were responsible for about
60,000 pages that had not been opened
being opened is so that I think that's
the next step what was the most
surprising thing other than the sheer
numbers of documents was I believe the
careful way in which the CIA and the FBI
tracked the event after it happened and
I think that the way in which the Lee
Harvey Oswald was tracked once they
realized that they had suffered some
missteps I had not recognized that he
would be an assassin I think all of
those things I think what is not
surprising is that we didn't find the
smoking gun that is you very rarely find
a particular record who's going to tell
is going to tell you everything you
really want to know
but you can put a lot together I also
would like to add that we had a category
of documents called enhancing the
historical understanding of the event
and we tried to put the assassination in
to a context so we opened a great many
documents on Cuba on the Cuban exiles a
group of people that have traditionally
been thought to be involved in the
assassination and we opened a great many
documents on the Mafia that the FBI had
because there another group of people
who have often been tied to the
assassination and then we even moved
into a few years of Vietnam because of
the suspicion the part of some people
that the Vietnam beginning of the
Vietnam War had something to do with the
assassination and so we really did go
into every corner but we did not make
any conclusions on a moderate one from
Louisville Kentucky
caller you're on with dr. Ellen Nelson
of American University yes you made a
statement early on that certain
documents were not released to the
public and that one of the reasons that
there might be people who might be
embarrassed by this and is this is there
going to be continued allegations that
the the cover-ups continued because
these documents were not released to the
public embarrassment had nothing to do
with it in fact the Central Intelligence
Agency was very happy to see us go out
of existence because we did not in fact
ever worry about embarrassment I'm
thinking instead of a person who was for
example in Mexico in an embassy who was
a double agent and whose family may very
well still be there and who could be
physically harmed that is the kind of
name that we covered we did make some
compromises on technical activities but
one of our mandates and something we did
consistently was when we took out
a word we put in a substitute it was
either a a technical meaning and
operational detail in the part of the
military was something that they still
use that was part of our statute we
couldn't reveal something that they
still use or it was a name or it was the
name of a CIA officer who had been
undercover and was in a foreign country
and had never been never said or
admitted that he was a CIA officer
because he had been undercover that's
the kind of name and we would always put
down name there were other instances
where we also had we have a little code
that goes along with the documents that
tells you what was covered but we never
covered anything for embarrassment that
was not a part of our thinking and I
have to tell you that there were five
people who came from many different
fields of history and law and never once
did we really disagree on what to open
that is none of us stood up and said no
no you can't open that the only time we
disagreed was when one of us wanted open
more when we would discuss whether or
not the privacy interests for example
were important enough or whether this
was really a technical operation that
was going and we were warned to consider
we were warned I'd say at least once
every three weeks in the first year of
our existence that we were releasing too
much and that it was going to destroy
American foreign policy etc etc but all
that's been in the archives for three
and a half years now for and and nothing
has quite happened yet
well dr. Nelson we have a great many
colors waiting but if you could just
tell us briefly you just mentioned the
other panel members who were they well
our chairman was a judge John tunheim
who joined us when he was Deputy
Attorney General of the state of
Minnesota and Kermit Hall who
a Dean at Ohio State University and a
constitutional historian William Joyce
who is the assistant librarian at
Princeton University in charge of
manuscripts rare books and Henry Graff
who was an emeritus professor from
Columbia University that's four isn't it
and me and I actually teach subjects
related to American foreign policy on
our conservative life from I believe
it's Louisville when it's in Mississippi
is that correct caller that's correct
morning good morning yes I have a little
bit of history in forensics as well as a
retired from the military as a military
policeman um and I was in high school
when Kennedy was assassinated and I was
just wondering um after all this time
why hasn't anyone come out and just
flat-out said that there is just no way
that he could have shot Kennedy from his
position with the type of rifle he had
with the accuracy that he had with the
bullet impacts that they are ascertained
from the angles you know it's just it's
just not possible unless he was Superman
so have y'all done incredible istic
checks on this the one ballistic check
that we have done and is not quite
completed although we had members of our
staff watching over the first part of
the study there is a little bullet
fragment left in the that the National
Archives has had in a box all this time
and the question was whether or not that
fragment had any kind of
a fabric attached something seemed to be
attached to it and so finally the
archives of course did not much want us
to disturb this artifact because it was
used in the Warren Commission and they
were fearful that it would be harmed but
ultimately they agreed unfortunately
they agreed very late in the game and
you will have to watch the newspaper or
the archives announcements or something
I don't myself know exactly how turned
out because we have we had we knew it
would take about until middle October
for them to actually finish the study we
because we were not an investigative
group we didn't go very much farther
than that the single Bullet theory came
out of the Warren Commission the House
Select Committee on assassinations in
the 70s said that it was impossible now
or two had to be two gunmen and you'll
be very interested in knowing that there
is an FBI document which says that their
double agent in Cuba heard that Fidel
Castro went out to try to to fire that
many times from the same kind of rifle
and couldn't do it and announced there
had to have been another killer at least
that's what the document says so I think
that's a controversy that will continue
and we did not find any evidence one way
or another we found no evidence of a
second killer we looked for all these
things very very hard it doesn't mean
there wasn't anyone there but we didn't
find it so you didn't come away a
conspiracy theorist
no I didn't historians tend not to be a
conspiracy theorist some of them are but
I think that we tend to see a lot of
many facets to a an assassination or to
any event I didn't come out of it not
being a theorist I just didn't it seems
to me that one of the basic problems
in tracking conspiracies is the
conspirators don't write it down
and so when you track the paper trail
and or even interview they're not going
to admit it on an interview so generally
the way you put together a conspiracy is
very tedious work in a collection of
records and then you make up your mind
and people disagree about conspiracies
from 500 years ago so I would imagine
there will still be disagreement but I
think now you can sit there and look at
all the evidence that we have
accumulated on our liberal life from
Vidalia Louisiana good morning good
morning ah something has always puzzled
me about the assassination for President
Kennedy within a week or so after he was
assassinated it just so happened that my
wife my children myself were going
through Dallas on our way to Fort Worth
we stopped to see what a president was
assassinated there was a lot of people
around there looking just sights is just
like I was on the street it they had
four squares painted out squares
probably eight foot by 12 foot and then
each square was painted for instance one
table was painted president's call for
you shot then the next one had
president's call second shot presidents
cosplayed shot what puzzles me is I'm
not the only one that was at it that
notices standing any squares you could
not see the window where ours was
supposed to be you had to walk way out
on this neutral ground facing a building
where Iowa was you had to walk to your
right and a window that had red tape an
outline of a man was supposed to be
holding a gun but you could not see it
from where the squares were painted on
the street
how could he shoot but he didn't see
well of course that's an issue that has
been raised also the distance from the
Book Depository window to Dealey Plaza I
know that in the years since Kennedy was
assassinated many of the trees had grown
up I can't answer your question because
I didn't see it in those years we did go
see it before we really got into
business and the assassination and and I
think everyone who goes there is struck
with another idea another fasted another
view of things I was struck with the
fact that when I was on the street in
Dealey Plaza I thought the window looked
very very far away but when I got up in
the Book Depository I could see the
straight shot now whether or not he
could at that time with the growth of
the trees and the other differences I
don't know we that's an investigative
matter we had a hard time drawing a line
between investigation and that was just
not our mandate but I think that's an
interesting story and I would imagine
that other people at the same time must
have must have wondered the same thing
Curtis Ohio you are moderate lying good
morning good morning Michael Piper
author of final judgment a book about
the Kennedy assassination asserts that
there was a dispute between President
Kennedy and the government of Israel
over the furnishing of nuclear
technology to Israel and as I understand
it
President Kennedy would not do that in
this book mr. Piper asserts the Israeli
most said of complicity in the
assassination of President Kennedy have
you found any evidence in your search we
found no evidence we found almost no
documents having to do with Israel I
think that book is one of maybe 500 that
are written about the assassination or
maybe not quite that many I know that
when I first joined the group
by the board I decided to turn on the
computer and see what was around and I
was astonished at this year numbers of
books on my suggestion is that he go
back and or anyone interested in that go
back and look and see I'd have no
recollection of anything having to do
with Israel but you know we didn't see
every document many of them came to the
archives all completely open and
therefore we didn't see them so going
through the database and looking for
that might prove useful to you our next
call is on the website I'm sorry I'm
sorry I'm saying the wrong thing I'm
sorry on a conservative line from San
Diego California good morning
I can't wanted to have my first question
would be can we get some clarification
on the website where this report has
posted an address or something like that
then my second is more of a statement my
second statement here is I am a proud
not so proud owner of an Italian
mannlicher-carcano built in 1938 my dad
bought it for me in 1960 for 12 bucks
it's the same weapon that was used the
same type of weapon that was used by Lee
Harvey Oswald during the middle sixties
I had fired the weapon but then I got
the chance to become a much better shot
at the request of the United States
government and got formal training and
how to shoot a gun and in 1968 was the
last time I fired that weapon and I took
it out to a dump and had the last damn
use no ammunition left for those types
of weapon anymore unless you want to
reload it and I still have it still
packed away but I remember trying to
fire off three accurate shots the period
of time that I forgot about distance was
three or four hundred yards
I tried to make those three shots and
I'll tell you something I couldn't come
within three feet of hitting the same
spot that I shot out first bullet with
go then was notoriously inaccurate if
the weapon was was very clumsy had a
very bad bolt action in it in fact it
was so bad that I stopped using the
weapon because many soldiers during
World War two were killed by the weapon
itself the bolt action was so rickety
that a highly charged powder charge from
one once a shell that blow the bolt out
of the weapon in in to stack in your
head it was a very very bad weapon even
there is a the weapon that he used is in
the archives because it was part of the
Warren Commission set of documents and
artifacts and we saw it some of the men
lifted it up I didn't but I think you're
I think you're right it was probably all
Lee Harvey Oswald could afford at the
time and that is one of the greatest
controversies is whether he could have
shot that many times and hit accurately
and it's it's unanswerable in terms of
what we found I think there will always
be speculation about that the Warren
Commission started that speculation by
coming up with what they call the single
Bullet theory that is that there had
been a lone gunman and and I think that
while the house committee disputed that
somewhat no one has ever found other
than the various theories anyone who has
come forward to say they participated in
that so we're left with the fact that
Oswald we know Oswald did shoot whether
he did
shoot all the bullets or not as a matter
of great contention with everyone
studying the way in which the president
was hit it get it can get a little
ghoulish if you really want to look at
it time and time and time again but it
has interested people greatly and I
don't have an answer to that and I'm not
so sure anybody does right now before
take our next call is backtrack a minute
what I was flailing to say incoherently
before was that this report can be found
at the website for the Federation of
American scientists as WWF fas.org I
apologize for my incoherent our next
call is on the liberal line from Vallejo
California good morning good morning I
see something other than the impeachment
uh yeah hearings so yeah I I was
somebody who thought Oswald was the only
person that you know shot the president
but I don't know after seeing Oliver
Stone's movie and I don't know if you
want to comment on that and
investigating what happened in the Bay
of Pigs and I think was the Louisiana
Attorney General that dude that tried
Clay Shaw a lot of interesting things
came up I know that when Kennedy came
into office that he shook up a lot of
people I know that he shook up the Mafia
I know Robert Kennedy was investigating
them and they had connections with Cuba
along with the Cuban Nationals the and
the CIA and he was so mad about what
happened baby pigs I know that he wanted
to span a CIA reduce military things and
it just seems to me that this one bullet
theory just just doesn't stand up and I
don't know when all the other material
for the wound reports going to be
released
I know it's sealed until sometime after
2000 and maybe they'll shed some light
but from from everything that I can see
now I really think there was more than
one person involved
in the shooting I mean if nobody can
actually duplicate that that kind of
shot from that window with that kind of
rifle the other thing is I don't think
Boswell was a super expert marksman
either from understand he was a radar
specialist in Japan at the same base
that garriepowers flew out of with the
u2 and that whole thing about him going
to Russia and how he got back and all
that kind of goes in to him being
involved with the CIA so I'm not kind of
convinced now that it's it's a
conspiracy and just kind of like to ask
you do you think that the other
information that's being under lock and
key at this point do you think it'll
shed some kind of light on that
conspiracy at that time there really
isn't any information under lock and key
except for the selected documents we
allowed to be under lock and key we
opened a Lauren report documents that
had been closed and we specifically were
told to open all of the House Select
Committee documents it took us a great
long time to do that then and you've hit
on a problem that has caused a lot of
suspicion and that is that every time we
had an investigation of the
assassination we hid the documents that
is everyone closed the documents and so
there was always a sense that there was
something back there now as for the
Louisiana trial it was a district
attorney Jim Garrison who was the hero
you might say of Oliver Stone's movie
who pursued Clay Shaw and took him to
trial only man who has ever tried for
the assassination show was astonished by
the way and in looking into that we
ripsi we received some documents from
the district attorney's office and some
grand jury documents and the some
documents from clay Shaw's lawyer and
also a diary that Clay Shaw kept and in
truth Jim Garrison and hence the Oliver
Stone movie has been discredited by
these documents here
and if you if you read them you see he
did not have a case he had nothing to
build it on and as you remember show I
think was the jury was out what 15
minutes 30 minutes something like that
he simply didn't have a case and for
that reason I think you can discard that
conspiracy now there's no question about
the fact that the Cuban exiles were very
angry at Kennedy and because he did not
support them when they were going into
the Bay of Pigs with air cover and so we
released a great many documents about
Cuba and the Cuban exiles and tried to
put a lot together for the reviewers
whether we never found a close tie but
then of course as I say you know I got
to find it written down the Mafia was
used we found that out in the 1970s from
a congressional form a Senate committee
the Mafia was used to approach a Castro
Castro was the subject of attempts
assassination but it's and while we have
released all of those documents it
really will be somebody somebody is
going to have to go through them piece
by piece but I think actually if I came
out on one side or another I'd say that
I came out not really thinking that
Oswald was connected to the CIA I think
we attribute too much efficiency to
these organizations I think if you if
you live around the federal government
or work in the federal government you
see that in fact they're not very
efficient I'm not quite sure how they
get together on a conspiracy of and so
you know they have behind the CIA in
those years barely spoke to each other
so I think that that's one of the
practical reasons why there was perhaps
not a conspiracy but in addition I think
that while you had a lot of people who
wanted to perhaps kill Kennedy
assassinating someone is not that easy
and what we hate to think of in this
country or perhaps any country is the
idea that one mentally unbalanced man
could change the course of history
whether it was by assassinating Abraham
Lincoln or way McKinley or John F
Kennedy and that's what happened that is
the assassination changed the course of
history was bound to and so I think we
really don't like to think that we would
prefer to think that there was some
hidden conspiracy behind it there is no
record that oswald was used by the CIA
at all they had discourage to come up
and find anything out about him if
anything they made the mistake of not
following him adequately enough when he
came back to this country on our
moderate line from Larusso Missouri good
morning how are you this morning
fine thank you oh I recently saw a
documentary on one of the networks or
cable whatever it may have been on some
private group that have been
investigating the assassination I guess
for some years and Oh back in my younger
days I was quite a rifle enthusiast and
in this approver film oh if you if I
don't know than anyone's ever noticed
this or not but you could see a bullet
hit the curb on the left side of
Kennedy's car you can see the powder fly
up from where that bullet hit that curb
of a district it's very obvious right
don't fulfill now these people claim
that this assassination was set up
originally set up by a group of the
Mafia in Chicago and that it was
actually done through the French mafia
out of France and their concern and
their reason for doing this was it
Castro of course it nationalized Cuba
and their casinos were losing millions
and millions of dollars a day and the
Castro was slightly involved but that
there were there were actually three
people involved in the shooting and the
idea was so they could be sure that they
actually killed Kennedy that they were
going to fire a from above on the rear
above from the front which was a grassy
knoll they have it enhanced a picture
there that pretty well shows a guy
standing back in there and the other
gunman was it was concealed in a
drainage deal down in the kind of street
level and he had an escape route that
went out through some of their sewer
tunnels or whatever that it took about
20 minutes to to get away but they they
claimed that they stayed in Dallas for
about ten days in a safe house after
that after the assassination that they
left there from there they went to
Chicago from Chicago they took a private
plane to Montreal and from Montreal back
to France and I I just saw this but you
can actually see the the concrete puffs
from where this this this one bullet
actually hit the curb across the process
on the opposite side of Kennedy's car
that but there there was a bullet that
totally missed everything and this this
one fellow that supposedly knows has all
this information is in prison in France
he was offered to contract to do this
assassination in well I think one of the
one of the things you have to remember
is that once there is a major historical
event
a lot of people would like to feel they
were involved in it and so a lot of
people have come forward I think that
the whole issue of the grassy knoll and
such is something that we will always
have with us and again my suggestion is
to go look at the documents now they're
there I'm sorry thank you so much for
joining us dr. Nelson we're just about
out of time
dr. nelson of american university was a
board member who issued this one of the
members who issued this final report on
the assassination records review of John
F Kennedy we will be joining the
Congress as they convene in a weekend
session to pass some spending bills
those they have to do in the next few
days thank you very much for joining us
and we look forward to seeing you next
time on Washington Journal